people laid flowers and candles for the
more than 30 animals that burn to death
in the Krefeld zoo overnight among the
dead animals are highly endangered apes
like orangutans from Borneo lowland
gorillas from Central Africa and
chimpanzees from West Africa shortly
after midnight fire broke out in the ape
house in the Cray field zoo police with
automatic weapons were brought in to
protect firefighters in case of attacks
from wild animals the ape house was also
home to fruit bats and birds they were
all killed in the blaze but two
chimpanzees survived the course of the
fire is not yet known but police believe
it may have started from flames in sky
lanterns launched for New Year witnesses
our sky lanterns in the air near the zoo
and some of them were flying very low we
have to assume they went down in the zoo
sky lanterns are banned almost
everywhere in Germany including the
state of North rhine-westphalia where
Cray field is located police are
treating the case as negligent arson